2017 will likely be remembered as a year
that victims shattered the silence
around sexual misconduct this morning we
are taking a look at the far-reaching
impact of the me2 movement it hit close
to home for many of us including some of
us all of us really here at CBS this
morning I decided that I had to speak up
if I didn't who was going to do it I
think the question is who protected the
women and who protected Harvey Weinstein
the board fired co-founder Harvey
Weinstein last night more's accusers say
the outspoken evangelicals sought them
out when they were as young as 14 in the
coming weeks I will be resigning as a
member of the United States Senate he
grabs the back of my head and just sort
of comes in and puts his lips right on
mine and just sticks his tongue in my
mouth but Tolley says he's stepping away
from it all following the allegations
Laura was let go one week after CBS News
fired Charlie Rose women cannot achieve
equality in the workplace or in society
until there is a reckoning and a taking
of responsibility the women who have not
spoken up because they're afraid I'm
hoping that now they will take the step
to speak out to that this becomes a
moment of truth there's a cultural shift
happening right before our eyes right
now Pandora's Box is opened and Pandora
is pissed two of the reporters who
started the national conversation with
their bombshell reporting on allegations
against Harvey Weinstein are here Jodi
Cantor's a New York Times reporter and
CBS News contributor Megan Chui is a New
York Times investigative reporter and
the two of these women broke this story
wide open I love Jane Rosenthal's
comment that pandora is pissed welcome
to you both Nora and I were both at the
Hearst luncheon recently were you two
got a standing ovation from women and
men in the room congratulating you on
the work that you've done so it's
interesting to read Jodi and Meghan that
before the story broke both of you said
is anybody gonna care about this isn't
there's just a Hollywood story nobody
even knows who Harvey Weinstein has
talked about that Jodi a little bit some
people said it's nope in secret
everybody in Hollywood is known for a
long time they told us they were denied
that we were naive and idealistic that
we would publish our little story and
life would go on
and and Megan what it has done is
essentially on unleashed a tidal wave of
reporting and allegations that's right I
mean I think this country is having well
it goes beyond the United States at this
point is having a real reckoning I mean
how was it that for so many years there
were men in a variety of industries who
were able to get away with predatory
behavior basically unchecked it's it's
obviously not the first story on this
subject but it's changed things and why
do you think it's changed things what's
what's the climate that suddenly made
this reckoning occur you think well
first of all things have been building
for a while for example a few months
before we published the Harvey Weinstein
story our colleagues published a story
revealing the settlement trail that Bill
O'Reilly had accumulated at Fox and so
we were beginning to see that first of
all we were able to report a little more
on these issues and that also the women
were being believed and that we saw the
beginnings of accountability to that
this could actually affect the careers
of men who had held power for a very
long time I asked you once in a
conversation I said do you think there's
a statue of limitations on behavior do
you think there is you know I think the
stories of things that happened a long
time ago are very important
I appreciate hearing women's stories
from the 60s from the 70s from the 80s
because I think these are the
foundations of our culture and we have
to understand them and part of the
project now is that all of us together
are kind of reconstructing the secret
history of how women have been harassed
in the American workplace and how its
held women back in the public sphere in
so many ways well I think one of the
points to that that you've made too is
that it talked about the narrative right
I mean who decides what movies are made
who decides who's in those movies I mean
and take that through every industry
about who are the decision-makers about
who's included and who's excluded yeah
there was an interesting moment and this
past year as this story continued to
unfold when Bill O'Reilly was forced to
step down following our colleagues you
know sensational reporting on all these
settlements that he had paid out to
women over the years and
made me think back to the previous year
when I was doing coverage of Trump's
treatment of women including allegations
of sexual misconduct against him and
Bill O'Reilly had gone on TV and said
Megan - we should not be able to do this
coverage because she's a feminist and I
think now we're seeing other questions
about who you know who should be allowed
to do you know who have been the voices
of various issues and coverage and
entertainment over the years are you
concerned at all because now I keep
hearing from men and from women - about
a potential me to backlash to Nora's
point about allegations that happened
long ago and that now a woman makes an
accusation and almost immediately men
are saying we don't get due process we
immediately get the death penalty and
that met all the allegations are the
same some behavior is predatory in
criminal and some is just bad jerky bad
behavior and inappropriate what do you
say about that Megan are you concerned
well I think that's a I think that's a
great question and I think you know
rounding the corner into 2018 we're at a
remarkable crossroads here for the first
time I think maybe ever you have a
culture in which women now feel
comfortable stepping forward and making
allegations when in the whereas in the
past they felt like they would be the
ones to suffer consequences to their
careers and and worse if they spoke out
and so I think though moving forward
it's going to be really important to
make sure that hey there are ways to
categorize these different allegations
that there's a difference between
allegations of rape and you know
inappropriate comments in a workplace
sexual misconduct can be a broad
category and I think we're gonna have to
figure out some categories that go
underneath it and I think we're also
gonna make sure that we moving forward
in workplaces that there are that there
is a due process that any ways in which
both the accused and the accusers are
legally protected but the women we
worked with who came on the record
talking about these allegations
they did not do so lightly they were
very brave and they were very serious
about it
they weren't discussing minor incidents
that they that were easy to brush off
and the reason they spoke up was that
they wanted to help other women
Hayek in the New York Times accusing
Harvey Weinstein monster this is a story
that she has been reluctant to share for
a while and it wasn't like she just laid
it out there it took some time can very
narrative to tell that story right
exactly exactly and I think that there's
been I think it's been a rare case in
which there was one or two women who
came forward with an allegation and it
stopped there I mean oftentimes what
we've seen is that you know that the
first or second allegation are then
followed by multiple allegations Meghan
quickly you mentioned the reporting on
president Trump allegations that are
still out there which he continues to
deny where do you see this going well
it's important to revisit the more than
ten women who came forward with
allegations of sexual misconduct of
against Trump during the presidential
race and not only that but as we we know
as we remember he was actually captured
on audiotape bragging about this type of
behavior on a you know inappropriate
touching and actually even sexual
assault and you know he denies it he
says he's actually never engaged in any
behavior like that in fact he you know
he turned around and accused every
single woman who came forward with
allegations against him as Liars and
said that they were politically
motivated
he threatened to sue the accusers he
threatened to sue me in the New York
Times and so I think it's a reminder of
how when allegations are made in a
political context I mean that was one of
the most polarizing races of in modern
political history how sometimes the
accusers can be framed as politically
motivated and but this story is not
going away those accusers are getting
more attention now in the last couple
months and that story I don't think is
going to go away Meghan tweed Jodie
canter thank you both very much thank
you